promo Paul à Montigny-le-Bretonneux qui
accueille donc depuis ce mardi matin les
rencontres créatives des conférences des
rencontres des échanges également entre
femmes chefs d'entreprise à l'initiation
de à l'initiative pardon de cette
association créative bonsoir Nathalie
Leroy vous en êtes la présidente bonsoir
à Géraldine dupontalier vous êtes l'une
des intervenantes vous êtes aussi toutes
les deux chefs d'entreprises Nathalie
Leroy creative a bientôt 10 ans 10 ans
cette année les rencontres c'est la
troisième édition de ces manifestations
est-ce que depuis tout ce temps les
choses ont évolué pour les femmes chefs
d'entreprise pour créative l'association
évolue puisque elle est en belle
croissance
je n'ai pas l'impression personnellement
que les choses est beaucoup changé pour
les femmes mais on essaie difficile
aujourd'hui quand on est une femme de
devenir chef d'entreprise c'est un peu
difficile de franchir le cap de se dire
qu'on peut être chef d'entreprise en
tout cas pour certaines femmes donc on
est là un peu pour les aider les inciter
à
passer cette étape on va découvrir le
chiffre tout de cette édition 170
000 c'est le nombre d'entreprises créées
par les femmes en 2011 32% des créations
sur cette année 2011 justement on peut
tout de même se dire que c'est
finalement un pas si mauvais chiffre 32%
c'est une c'est une croissance par
rapport aux années précédentes quelles
sont les difficultés par exemple que
vous vous avez rencontré pour créer
votre entreprise
écoutez moi j'ai créé mon entreprise il
y a déjà plus de 10 ans donc ça commence
à être une vieille histoire
les difficultés que j'ai rencontrées ce
sont les difficultés finalement
peut-être pas liées au féminin mais
c'est surtout des difficultés liées à la
prospection au fait de trouver de
nouveaux clients à m'installer dans
cette profession et à gagner en
crédibilité ça c'est quelque chose qui
se construit sur le long terme
je pense pas que ce soit plus difficile
lorsque l'on est une femme
mais le fait d'être effectivement
ensemble chez Creative est un bon moyen
de se ressourcer trouver des leviers de
motivation et de te donner envie d'y
aller tous les jours avec réactif
justement vous vouliez rompre cet
isolement des femmes chefs d'entreprise
vous avez le sentiment d'avoir réussi
véritablement et comment vous avez
réussi alors quels sont les leviers que
vous en fait on se voit une fois par
mois
autour d'un thème d'une réunion sur un
thème lié à l'entreprise ou à son
développement et c'est l'occasion
justement de confronter nos expériences
d'apprendre et d'échanger et c'est une
manière de sortir de l'isolement et le
point d'orgue c'est rendez-vous c'est
rencontre qui se déroulent depuis ce
matin ça se poursuit d'ailleurs si vous
nous suivez en direct ce soir vous allez
continuer les différentes réunions il y
a encore d'autres manifestations ce soir
tout à fait ce soir à partir de 18h30
nous avons un débat sur les synergies
possibles entre les TPE les toutes
petites entreprises et les grands
groupes
et ensuite effectivement une soirée
networking c'est une soirée où les
entrepreneurs se rencontrent échangent
leur carte de visite pour se connaître
éventuellement faire du business
ensemble
et ce sera au programme de ce soir juste
une petite pause on va écouter les
Yvelines à présent quelle image
avez-vous des femmes chefs d'entreprises
c'est la question que nous avons posée
la question du jour
c'est la même chose mais dans le sexe
opposé si les femmes ont fait des études
c'est aussi pour devenir un jour chef
d'entreprise donc moi je suis pour rien
pas de raison ça n'a rien de surprenant
que la femme soit au même niveau voire
même au niveau supérieur par rapport aux
certaines l'image une femme libre et
dynamique
au moins aussi compétentes que les
hommes très bonne gestionnaires voilà
après ça faut pouvoir tout assumer je
pense que ça se fait pas sans un certain
nombre de sacrifice quelque part une
femme qui a réussi
les cheveux courts
un joli minois je trouve que c'est bien
qu'en fin les femmes puissent être à la
tête d'entreprise je sais que pour elle
c'est beaucoup plus difficile que pour
les hommes
mais bon quelquefois on les accuse de
quoi d'hystérie ou d'autoritarisme mais
quand il s'agit d'un homme on ne dit
rien de tout ça donc moi je suis pour
les femmes au pouvoir
les femmes au pouvoir et cette
information essentielle il faut avoir
les cheveux courts pour être entreprises
ça a été dit dans le micro-trottoir on
l'a entendu tout à l'heure ça critère
chez nous Frédéric du lac vous êtes élu
à Magny-les-Hameaux vous êtes avec nous
pour évoquer les manifestations qui se
déroulent autour de la semaine de la
Quinzaine même des femmes que vous
organisez sur la commune il y a
plusieurs manifestations on viendra sur
le programme tout à l'heure mais vous
êtes aussi responsable politique mais
adjointe à Mani les hameaux lorsqu'on
est une femme faire de la politique
c'est aussi plus difficile comme pour
les chefs d'entreprise
a priori non a priori non et puis au fil
du temps s'aperçoit que finalement c'est
pas si simple que on n'est pas tout à
fait traité de la même façon
il y a des préjugés il y a
rencontré des difficultés des
difficultés non mais pour se faire
entendre oui pour se faire entendre il
faut répéter alors que les hommes n'ont
pas à répéter voilà je pense à mes
collègues aussi parce que
il faut parler plus fort en conseil
municipal pourtant municipal non si vous
laissez dans l'équipe de qui sont en
très très bien de la majorité etc
non pas du tout mais le savent ils le
savent mais c'est surtout ceux qui sont
tout en haut quoi et bon le maire par
exemple ira plus vite avec un homme
qu'avec une femme la femme il faudra
qu'elle revienne redire son sujet pour
être sûr qu'il y en a bien compris ce
qu'elle voulait dire le fond sa pensée
que ça peut être interprété etc et c'est
vrai que bon je suis pas la seule à dire
ça dans on se fait des petites réunions
un petit peu féminines pour parler de
tout ça entre nous on aura l'occasion de
lui poser la question la prochaine fois
qu'il viendra sur ce plateau
oui mais c'est parce que c'est une
question de génération aussi si vous
voulez c'est pas c'est on lui en veux
pas pour ça c'est vrai qu'il y a eu un
changement de génération avec ce
changement de merde sur la ville de
Magny-les-Hameaux pour être mon fils
alors maintenant ça change les rapports
effectivement on en revient en rencontre
créative qui se déroule actuellement du
côté de Montigny-le-Bretonneux depuis ce
matin quel bilan on peut faire sur la
fréquentation et puis sur la qualité
aussi des échanges alors sur la
fréquentation allez je pense similaire à
l'an dernier on a des conférences bien
remplies des salles qui remplissent à
peu près 40 personnes
dans les couloirs sur les stands on a un
peu moins de monde mais je pense que la
météo y est pour beaucoup il fait un peu
froid
à limiter peut-être la fréquentation va
se rendre du côté de Promopole la
rédaction Julie Rocha Suarez et le
dimone se sont rendus lors de ces
différentes conférences et vous allez
voir qu'il était notamment question de
féminitude
entreprendre au féminin troisième
édition des Rencontres créatives à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux l'association de
femmes chefs d'entreprise était réunies
pour s'entraider et accompagner les
porteuses de projets l'occasion de
s'intéresser à la féminitude l'art de ce
servir de ses attributs et a tout
féminins féminitude c'est aussi le nom
du jeu de cartes que Marianne est rare
utilise pour le développement personnel
de ses clientes le tirage que je fais
très souvent c'est un tirage en 3 c'est
une carte qui représente la personne une
carte qui va représenter plutôt le frein
c'est à dire ce qu'il faudrait
travailler ça une carte qui représente
le potentiel qui va permettre de
travailler sur le frein et de se
réaliser et de se retrouver d'être
soi-même la solidarité féminine est le
maître mot de l'association créative
c'est sur ce même concept qui est né le
réseau social féminin mais bonne
copine.com il y a 7 mois 19000 inscrites
qui proposent gratuitement aux autres
femmes leurs compétences la fondatrice
est en pleine levée de fonds c'est pas
évident de d'être forcément
entendu crédible face à une assemblée
d'hommes un petit peu âgées environ une
soixantaine d'années de moyenne d'âge et
d'être entendu prise au sérieux moi
après au bout de 5 minutes la crédité se
met en place mais il y a un petit un
petit temps on va dire de suspicion
voilà d'amusement on va dire l'autre
difficulté gérer vie familiale et vie
professionnelle comme pour cette
créatrice maman de trois enfants je crée
c'est moi qui fabrique il faut aussi en
même temps aller négocier avec les
fournisseurs pour obtenir des meilleurs
prix etc il faut aussi s'occuper de tout
ce qui est communication alors même si
c'est mon métier de départ
il faut quand même avoir le temps de le
faire il a fallu créer une boutique en
ligne tout ça ça prend du temps et puis
en même temps vendre être chef
d'entreprise pour résumer c'est surtout
une question de passion et
d'investissement
voilà pour l'une des conférences qui
s'est déroulée aujourd'hui à Promopole
dans le cadre des Rencontres créatives
aux abordez les différents problèmes
différentes thématiques liées aux femmes
il y a aussi des sujets qui concernent
tous les chefs d'entreprise homme ou
femme et notamment ce question du
management cette question du management
de la génération Y sont les plus jeunes
qui arrivent sur le marché du travail
c'était le thème de votre intervention
justement alors cette génération Y déjà
comment on la définit tout le monde
n'est pas d'accord sur les dates alors
grosso modo on peut dire que la
génération qui est née entre 1978 et
1994 voilà si on veut à peu près donner
donner cet ordre d'idée ces jeunes là
pourquoi sont-ils plus difficiles ces
jeunes et un petit peu moins jeunes
d'ailleurs ils sont pas plus difficiles
au contraire et représentent de
formidables atouts pour les managers et
c'est le message que je voudrais faire
passer
ils ont des codes qui sont différents
des générations précédentes ils arrivent
aujourd'hui dans un contexte de crise
donc il faut qu'il soit plus créatif et
leur grandes chances c'est qu'ils sont
en communauté en réseau avec cette
capacité à échanger
capacité plusieurs cerveaux pour obtenir
de nouvelles idées
des jeunes qui sont aussi beaucoup plus
autonomes que les générations
précédentes puisqu’effectivement ils
peuvent aller chercher l'information
partout mais aussi des jeunes qui sont
plus exigeants vis-à-vis de leur manager
puisqu'ils les remettent en cause ils
veulent savoir pourquoi tout le temps en
anglais ça fait les générations
exactement la génération pourquoi la
générations c'est aussi le y la forme
des écouteurs
et c'est aussi la génération pourquoi la
génération pourquoi la quête de sens ça
c'est typiquement ce qui caractérise la
génération de faire quelque chose il
faut qu'il y a une explication une
motivation pour le manager se doit
d'être aujourd'hui un communicant
absolument c'est un incontournable il
l'a toujours été mais encore plus
aujourd'hui quelles sont les clés que
vous donnez justement c'est ne pas se
braquer par exemple ne pas se braquer
accepter d'être remis en cause ça c'est
quelque chose qui est pas évident quand
on a le statut et l'autorité statutaire
c'est accepté aussi d'expliquer c'est
accepté aussi de rentrer en relation
réellement avec ses collaborateurs ces
jeunes collaborateurs pour savoir ce qui
se passe aussi dans leur vie privée
la vie privée en quête de plus en plus
sur la ville au travail
sa vie privée à l'intérieur de
l'entreprise par le biais des réseaux
justement et ce qu'elle attend de son
manager c'est qu'effectivement ce
manager puisse échanger avec elle autour
de ce qui se passe dans l'ensemble du
système qui la caractérise vous avez
réussi à faire passer le message cet
après-midi alors on a on a communiqué on
a échangé on a aussi beaucoup ri parce
que dans dans l'assemblée qui était
vraiment il y avait un une personne de
la génération Y et on lui demandait
constamment s'il était d'accord avec ce
qu'on disait ne me demandez pas si je
suis d'accord
aux portes de cette génération là être
une femme est-ce que ça permet de mieux
appréhender peut-être cette génération
là oui je crois que en fait ce qui
caractérise le leadership au féminin
c'est un leadership qui est plus
émotionnel plus centré sur l'émotion sur
le ressenti et sur donc le relationnel
et ça c'est incontestablement une force
si l'on veut rentrer en communication
mieux avec la génération Y et nécessite
un management de plus en plus émotionnel
pas simplement un management
participatif mais aussi un management
plus centré sur les émotions oui
incontestablement c'est une merci
Géraldine Dupont calvier merci à
Nathalie Leroy on va vous laisser
repartir justement sur ces rendez-vous
créatifs qui se prolongent à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux juste une toute
dernière question les chiffres du
chômage qui ont été communiqués en toute
fin de fin de journée plus 5,4 % de
chômeurs en France en janvier 48000
demandeurs d'emploi en plus soit plus de
4 millions 4 millions 680 000 personnes
inscrites à Pôle emploi au milieu de
tous ces inscrits au chômage il y a des
inscrits aussi des femmes est-ce que les
femmes sont plus touchées par le chômage
qu'elle retourne vous pouvez avoir ces
dernières mois avec les difficultés la
crise économique actuelle des
différentes chefs d'entreprise est-ce
que certaines ont raccroché justement
sont passés à autre chose en fait
souvent les femmes qui s'orientent vers
l'entrepreneuriat créent leur propre
emploi avant même de chercher à créer
des emplois pour les autres ça c'est la
cerise sur le gâteau mais elles vont
chercher à créer leur propre emploi ils
y arrivent plutôt bien donc elles sont
de plus en plus nombreuses actuellement
j'ai pas les les chiffres même son
chiffre
c'est difficile de dissocier ce qu'il
advient des femmes en cas d'emploi et
les chiffres de créatives puisque
l'association est un croissant
indépendamment de la situation
économique donc c'est un petit peu
difficile de savoir
d'entreprise qui se sont lancées il y a
une dizaine d'années en même temps que
l'association aujourd'hui elles en sont
où alors certaines d'entre elles
continuent on a de plus en plus
j'ai l'impression on a beaucoup de
membres qui ont quitté l'association au
fil du temps au fil du cours de la vie
qui reste dans l'association et qui font
croître leur entreprise merci à toutes
les deux d'être venu donc sur ce plateau
parler de ces rencontres réactives
entreprendre au féminin Frédéric Dulac
vous restez donc en plateau avec nous on
va se pencher sur les animations qui
sont proposées du côté de Manille les
hameaux avec ce rendez-vous femme du
monde